Olha essa notícia que saiu agora. Você
não precisa virar um grego para ter os
benefícios da dieta mediterrânea. Pois
é, sai um estudo bem interessante
mostrando isso. Os pesquisadores
acompanharam quase 5.000 pessoas por 6
anos, todas com sobrepeso e síndrome
metabólica. O grupo que fez uma versão
mais leve da dieta mediterrânea,
reduzindo calorias e fazendo exercício
regular, teve resultados
impressionantes. Perdeu em média 3,3 kg,
reduziu a barriga e diminuiu em até 31%
o risco de desenvolver o diabético 2.
Veja bem, a dieta mediterrânea é rica em
azeite, frutas, legumes, grãos
integrais, peixes e castanhas. Isso
melhora a sensibilidade insulina, reduz
inflamações crônicas, são justamente os
fatores que levam diabetes. O legal é
que você não precisa ser radical, mesmo
uma versão mais suave, priorizando uma
comida de verdade, aliando ao exercício
físico, já traz um impacto enorme na sua
saúde metabólica. É isso que é
sustentável a longo prazo.